The Fascinating Saga of the Chicken War or
Why There are So Few Truck Models in the US
Ever wonder why if you want to buy a truck
in the United States you have drastically
fewer selections than many other countries
tend to enjoy and why U.S.-made trucks dominate
the market in the country, while the same
ratios aren’t seen at all in cars?
It’s all because of chickens.
No, really.
Before the twentieth century, chicken wasn’t
nearly as common of an item on people’s
dinner plates as today and was very much a
luxury item mostly restricted to the wealthy
in Europe.
(In fact, chickens were actually originally
domesticated for cock-fighting, not food.)
Improvements in food storage via refrigeration
(see: Why Chicken Goes Bad So Quickly), refinements
in chicken breeding, and the development of
the so called “factory chicken” helped
change chicken consumption in the United States
and then the world.
So what does this have to do with the truck
market in the United States?
The U.S. began producing so much chicken that
businesses started exporting it to Europe
in massive quantities by the early 1960s,
peaking at the United States owning half the
chicken import market in Europe.
European farmers simply could not keep up
with the much lower prices of imported American
poultry.
For instance, in West Germany, only 1.1% of
imported chicken came from the United States
in 1956; six years later, despite the cost
and effort of shipping the chickens all the
way from America, American poultry made up
nearly a quarter of all West German chicken
imports and was sold for much less than the
local varieties.
Accusations against the American poultry industry
soon began to fly, with claims from the Dutch
that the American chickens were being purposely
priced below cost to drive the Dutch poultry
farmers out of business; the West Germans
accused American chicken farmers of using
arsenic to cause the chickens to gain extra
weight, while the French poultry farmers claimed
eating American chickens would have a negative
effect on one’s virility.
In response to the United States’ poultry
rapidly taking over the market in many European
countries, the European Economic Community
(EEC) in 1962 instituted a tariff on imported
chicken.
Officially, the goal of the EEC was to help
the European economy continue to recover from
World War II.
The tariff drastically raised the price of
imported U.S. poultry and some countries even
banned U.S. chicken all together.
The U.S. government spent eighteen months
trying to negotiate a repeal of the tariff
and bans, but without success.
The then Chancellor of Germany, Konrad Adenauer,
even later reported that, despite the Cold
War threatening to get very hot, “about
half” of his many conversations with Kennedy
were about chickens.
Senator J. William Fulbright of Arkansas even
once interrupted a NATO meeting on nuclear
armament to threaten to remove U.S. troops
from NATO if the chicken sanctions weren’t
removed.
The whole thing, waged between allies in the
Cold War, ultimately became dubbed “The
Chicken War.”
After diplomacy failed, in retaliation, President
Lyndon B. Johnson signed the so-called Chicken
Tax into law on December 4, 1963.
Not at all directly about chickens, it targeted
potato starch, brandy, dextrin, and light
trucks, and it forced companies importing
those items to the United States to pay a
whopping 25% tax on said imports.
Each of the four products taxed under the
Chicken Tax were strategically targeted.
For instance, the reason for choosing to include
light trucks had to do with a specific manufacturer:
Volkswagen.
The Volkswagen vans were immensely popular
in the United States during the early 1960s,
and the U.S. government claimed the import
cost of those from West Germany was about
equal to the loss of revenue for the poultry
industry at not being able to export chicken
to West Germany.
Practically overnight, the once popular VW
van, which fell under the classification of
“light truck,” disappeared from car dealerships
around the United States as consumers weren’t
willing to pay the increased prices directly
resulting from the 25% tariff.
Of course, there were other industries Johnson
could have picked to balance things out.
As to why specifically the light-truck industry
was one selection, there was a political benefit
to him at home.
Recordings from his time in the White House
later revealed an arrangement between Johnson
and Walter Reuther, the president of the United
Auto Workers.
In exchange for Johnson targeting Volkswagen,
Reuther agreed not to call a strike of auto
workers ahead of the 1964 presidential election
and to agree to support Johnson’s work in
civil rights.
However, it should also be noted that the
Chicken Tax was not so specifically worded
to be levied just against Europeans manufactures,
but against any automaker who imports light
trucks into the United States.
While most manufacturers chose simply not
to sell their trucks in the U.S. anymore,
or decided to build plants in the U.S. to
produce at least some of their light truck
lines, like Honda and Toyota, others discovered
clever loopholes to import their trucks and
cargo vans without paying the exorbitant tax.
For instance, certain Japanese companies started
exporting pickup trucks without the bed or
box attached to the U.S. rather than the fully
assembled pickup truck.
This ultimately made them only subject to
a 4% tax, and the manufacturers simply attached
the bed or box once the truck arrived in the
U.S.
However, this loophole was removed in 1980
at the request of U.S. automakers and unions,
making these imports subject to the 25% tax.
Another loophole truck manufacturers still
take advantage of is the difference between
a passenger vehicle and a truck- one, of course,
is designed to haul passengers and the other
cargo, but the passenger vehicle is only subject
to a 2.5% tax.
So, for instance, as recently as 2012, Ford
(ironically enough an American company this
tariff normally helps) built its Transit Connect
vans in Turkey and outfitted them with seats,
glass windows, and seatbelts in the back.
They were then shipped to the U.S. and passed
through customs as passenger vehicles.
The vans then went to a warehouse where local
contractors removed the seats and windows
from the back, replacing them with a floor
piece and steel respectively to transform
the Transit Connect into a commercial van
for hauling cargo.
This loophole was also closed up when U.S.
Customs ultimately forced the company to start
paying the 25% tax on these vehicles as of
March 2013.
Ford lobbyists then began pushing for removing
the tax for American-based companies, even
on their imports, but keeping it for everyone
else.
The Mercedes-Benz Sprinter van goes a different
route before arriving in the United States.
While passenger versions of the van are immune
to the Chicken Tax, the cargo versions cannot
normally be imported to the U.S. without the
tax.
So Mercedes-Benz ships the cargo version in
a sort of kit form, only partially built,
making sure to leave the kit incomplete enough
so that when it’s assembled in the U.S.,
just enough parts are purchased and added
in America to not have the authorities getting
too upset about it.
The process costs Mercedes-Benz quite a bit,
resulting in an increase in the cost of the
van of about 9%.
Of course, 9% is better than 25%.
In the years since the chicken tax was made
into law, the taxes on three of the four items
have been repealed, but, as you might have
guessed from those relatively recent examples,
the tax on light trucks remains.
Proponents claim the tax helps protect American
companies and keeps jobs in America.
Opponents note that before the Chicken Tax,
the “Big Three” American automakers featured
numerous types of light trucks and cargo vans
in their product lines, but since then the
Chicken Tax has “insulated U.S. truck manufacturers
from competition for five long decades.
That’s kept prices high and created huge
profit centers at Chrysler, Ford, and General
Motors — so much so… that the Big Three
have slacked off in developing innovative
cars…”
It has also been suggested that not only would
U.S. consumers get a greater variety of trucks
to pick from if the tariff was removed, but
the prices would also likely fall with increased
competition, bringing profit margins on trucks
and cargo vans more in line with car sale
profit margins for U.S. automakers, providing
a net benefit to U.S. consumers.
Whatever side of the argument one’s on,
it is, at the least, a fascinating piece of
history that is still unfolding today.